President Trump plans to visit El Paso
Texas and Dayton Ohio tomorrow as the
nation grapples with the deadly mass
shootings in both cities the death toll
from the two weekend shootings rose to
at least 31 yesterday those victims are
among more than 80 people killed or
injured in both Dayton and El Paso
within the span of just 13 hours we're
learning new details about the accused
gunman in El Paso who allegedly killed
22 people out of Walmart investigators
are piecing together his timeline and
motive leading up to the shooting
CBS this morning lead national
correspondent David Begg know is in El
Paso good morning David what more do we
know this morning well we know more
about how police say the gunman got here
but first I should tell you it just
started raining and that has dimmed the
glow of the candles which lined the
memorial here it's very quiet this
morning not many people but police media
and the crime scene tape that is still
up we're getting new information as it
relates to the investigation in that
police say it appears the Walmart was
chosen randomly authorities now tell CBS
News that the government apparently got
lost in a neighborhood before he wound
up at the Walmart and started shooting
police now tell us the suspected shooter
Patrick rucious after driving 10 hours
from his home in Allen which is near
Dallas to El Paso stopped at the Wal
Mart on Saturday because he was hungry
and randomly chose the Walmart to carry
out his attack authorities say Cruz who
is now in custody and being held without
bail has been unemployed for five months
and was on food stamps but he bought his
high-powered rifle legally police say a
racist manifesto that they believe was
written by Cruces and posted online
before the shooting criticized a growing
Hispanic population in Texas that kept
saying I need to find my kids
CBS Evening News anchor Noor O'Donnell
spoke to Ray Garcia who raced to the
scene and pulled several kids from a
girl's soccer team to safety why did you
run towards the danger because
kids because of the kids I was the most
important for me was the kids getting my
getting them out of there I didn't want
them to keep suffering like they were I
mean they they were crying and they had
seen too much very no pass was a family
and we must continue to stand united as
our region heals authorities have now
identified all 22 of the people who died
at least seven are Mexican nationals
El Paso mayor D Margo Val's that his
city will stand strong in the face of
evil
well boarders may separate us our grief
transcends them we're one region and we
will honor every victim like they were a
member of our community the people of El
Paso are searching for ways to process
their grief we went to new mass
yesterday with Javier Prado he is now a
US citizen who moved here from Mexico to
go to college I think the worst thing
that we can do as a community is staying
here we need to
sure support and show that everyone know
we're not gonna be intimidated Xavier
and others told us that they believe in
some way president Trump's
anti-immigrant rhetoric contributed to
what happens here that was their opinion
congressman with Roenick escobar who's a
Democrat says the president is not
welcome here but yesterday the mayor of
El Paso said his mayor it was his formal
duty to invite the president he stands
by it Dane I should tell you that El
Paso prides itself on having one of the
lowest crime rates there were 23 murders
here last year 23 and in one horrific
act there were 22 David those numbers
really give you perspective and a great
message from Javier to not be
intimidated for so many thank you David